bien ne reprenons nos travaux merci
monsieur mon cœur général
d'être ce soir au Sénat
devant la commission des lois qui
continue ses auditions dans une mission
qu'elle s'est donnée et qu'elle a confié
que particulièrement à Madame belureau
et Monsieur Durand sur
modification en tous les cas la
réalisation de la police nationale avec
le point particulier ou le jeudi à la
prolet la problématique particulière
pardon de la police judiciaire nous
avons vu comme tout le monde un certain
nombre de réactions
qui se sont fait connaître pour une
manifester un désaccord sur la manière
dont les choses pouvaient s'organiser
aux manifester des inquiétudes
à l'égard du fonctionnement futur de la
police judiciaire de ses relations avec
la justice naturellement à l'époqueurs
de la République ou les jeux
d'instruction et donc c'est dans ce
contexte là que vous êtes présent ce
soir et que l'on souhaite recueillir
votre point de vue puisque vous êtes
effectivement exprimé sur le sujet donc
madame bellerault monsieur Durand sont
les deux rapporteurs les autres
collections là et comme nous faisons
d'habitude on va vous donner la parole
et puis ensuite il y aura sans doute
évidemment
la question naturellement vous indiquez
que le rapport que qui se prépare en
tous les cas sur quel travail leur
rapporteur est programmé pour plutôt le
début de l'année il y a moins de mais il
y a un travail de fond qui est engagé
voilà merci je vous rappelle à toutes et
à tous et à vous monsieur en général que
nous sommes retransmis sur le site
internet du Sénat je me parle sur votre
contrôle donc de façon à ce que chacun
sache qu'il est observé
voilà
je sais pas comment vous souhaitez qu'on
procède moi je pensais faire une petite
déclaration liminaire
vous avez eu l'amabilité de me faire
passer un salon de questions pour
lesquelles j'ai préparé des réponses
donc si vous voulez je peux dérouler les
questions et les réponses et puis après
je serai à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes questions vous
souhaiterez me poser quand je veux
d'abord remercier le la commission
d'avoir souhaité m'entendre et de me
faire part de mes observations qui
finalement sont faites un peu un double
titre d'abord avec effectivement mes
fonctions actuelles
j'y reviendrai et puis j'ai quand même
été plus de 40 ans magistrats du parquet
ce qui fait que effectivement lorsque je
suis passé à France Inter à la fin du
mois d'août j'ai eu droit à une question
non auditeur vous connaissez le format
et j'ai répondu sur effectivement ce que
j'en pensais faudrait peut-être
commencer déjà par rappeler les
principes
qu'il faut pas oublier
l'article 12 du code pro sur pénal donc
la police judiciaire est exercée sous la
direction du procureur de la République
donc sous la direction des parquetiers
pour les enquêtes et sous l'autorité des
jeux d'instructions pour les
investigations effectuées sur la
commission obligatoire et ce qui me
paraît important de rappeler au-delà des
principes et des rappels de principe
c'est que ce principe est un principe à
valeur constitutionnelle puisque depuis
de mémoire la décision rendue par le
conseil sur la loopsie le 10 mars 2011
le Conseil a bien affirmé qu'il
résultait de l'article 66 de la
Constitution que la PJ devait être
placée sous la direction et le contrôle
d'autorité judiciaire que à cette fin
les articles qui suivent dans le code de
posture pénal assuré effectivement
le contrôle dirait direct effectivement
l'autorité judiciaire sur les officiers
et les agents de police judiciaires
principes qui est donc fondé
essentiellement sur le fait que
contrairement à la constitution les
magistrats sont gardiens de la liberté
individuelle et principe se découle un
certain nombre de conséquences et
d'abord bien évidemment
inquiéter essentiel c'est le principe du
libre choix du service enquêteur par le
procure de la République où le jeu
d'instruction j'ajouterai que c'est
aussi un moyen qui est indispensable
pour que le procureur de la République
au travers des enquêtes qu'il diligentes
puissent mettre en œuvre la politique
pénale qui a été décidée par décider par
le gouvernement et qui résulte des
circulaires qui vous sont adressés par
la garde des sceaux et c'est bien au nom
de ces principes que le 26 octobre
dernier ça pourrait paraître improbable
comme ça s'étonnant je pense de ces
principes que le Conseil supérieur à la
magistrature garant de l'indépendance de
la justice en assistante le président de
la République a souhaité faire de part
de sa préoccupation au regard du contenu
de cette réforme donc je voudrais
d'abord à ce stade peut-être
invoquer certaines nuances et insister
sur le fait que les propos publics que
j'ai pu tenir à la radio sur la mise en
œuvre de cette réforme date de la fin du
mois d'août puisque vous savez que
depuis face à l'unanimité des critiques
plusieurs interventions de monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et du directeur
général de la police nationale sont
venus préciser voir amodié les contours
du projet qu'ils envisagent qui est si
j'ai bien compris toujours en cours de
construction ce qui complique
effectivement quand même la mise en
oeuvre d'une telle réforme dont il reste
toujours délicat en tout cas moi je le
distrais moi de ce moment pour moi
d'apprécier aujourd'hui les contours
exacts et les effets concrets puisque si
j'ai bien compris le ministère de
l'Intérieur évoque maintenant des
garanties du respect du principe de
direction de la PJ par les procureurs de
même j'ai entendu dire que l'échelon
zonal serait préservé qu'il n'y aurait
pas de départementalisation de la police
judiciaire ni une modification des
offices et de leurs antennes j'en sais
pas plus donc je pense que l'exercice
dans lequel vous me demandez d'entrer
consiste peut-être davantage à bien
cibler les différents enjeux au regard
de l'expérience que j'ai eu sur le
traitement de certaines formes de
criminalité
éventuellement c'est ces différentes
annonces qui ont été faites semblent
semble répondre déjà à des inquiétudes
qui ont été
considérés qu'elles répondent déjà moi
j'attends de voir les pures définitives
du projet pour me prononcer là-dessus
simplement je déduis de des annonces qui
ont été faites que les critiques en tout
cas avaient été entendues et que
visiblement le ministère de l'Intérieur
travaillait à des évolutions ça me
paraît d'autant plus nécessaire que
longtemps on en a pas parlé mais les
résultats des expérimentations demeure
très mitigées au regard des informations
qui nous remontent du terrain vous savez
que dans la justice on n'est pas très
nombreux donc on échange beaucoup à tel
point qu'une mission d'évaluation a été
décidée à travers l'intervention de
trois corps d'inspection des mystères de
l'Intérieur et de la justice moi ce que
je voudrais dire à binicio c'est que je
suis pas de ceux qui disent que la
police n'a pas besoin d'être réformée il
y a certainement besoin d'une réforme
pour améliorer l'organisation le
fonctionnement et pour améliorer le
traitement des criminalités quotidien
simplement les échos dont on peut faire
état quand on est magistrat c'est que en
réalité je pense qu'on est dans une
situation de crise aujourd'hui puisque
il faut bien comprendre que la police ne
se réduit pas à la police aux effectifs
de police en tenue bleu sur la voie
publique et que il faut bien comprendre
que si les interpellations en fait par
les policiers ne sont pas suivis de par
des investigations de police complète et
impartiale et bien la justice qui fit ne
peut pas être de qualité la police
judiciaire c'est la police de la preuve
et il est donc indispensable que les
investigations qui soient diligentes
soient complètes soit exhaustive soit
impartial et que la procédure soit de
bonne qualité or on vit actuellement une
époque d'une situation de crise qui est
due à plusieurs facteurs et d'abord une
désinfection pour la police judiciaire
et pour l'investigation qui se traduit
par un déficit de vocation et
d'attractivité et par suite de
sous-effectif il suffit de lire le
rapport on se rend compte qu'à 17000 OPJ
alors qu'il en faudrait 22000
il en faut donc davantage mais c'est
comme les médecins il faut pas non plus
baisser la qualité de la formation il
faut qu'il soit toujours aussi bien
formé la complexification de la
procédure pénale j'en dirai pas plus
là-dessus à la commission des Lois du
Sénat qui c'est ça aussi bien systémique
que moi la réforme des corps et
carrières de la police nationale de 1995
qui dans les services de sécurité
publique a vu un désengagement majeur du
judiciaire des commissaires et de
l'encadrement supérieur des stocks de
procédure en souffrance dans les
commissariats qui s'aggravent
constamment les dernières estimations
font état de 2 millions de procédures en
souffrance dans non traité c'est fait
quand même beaucoup sur un volume de 5
millions 9 c'est quasiment entière et
qui seront donc pour la plupart très
vraisemblablement classés contrairement
au travail qui a été préconisé par le
ministère auprès des parquets dans cette
circulaire de mai 2021 donc ce sont là
aussi autant de victimes qui ont déposé
plainte qui ne recevons
vraisemblablement jamais de réponse
des délais de traitement qui de
traitement d'enquête qui s'allonge et
enfin tous les magistrats font ce
constat le constat d'une dégradation
constante de la qualité des procédures
pénales particulièrement sécurité
publique dégradation qui tient autant à
l'insuffisance effective qu'elle
insuffisance qualité procédurale des
enquêteurs de la sécurité publique alors
même qu'ils assurent plus de 90% des
missions d'investigation c'est pas le
cas par contre pour la police judiciaire
qui je pense à soutenir et préserver un
bon niveau de qualité sur les enquêtes
qui lui sont confiants mater de grandes
criminalités organisés financière enfin
j'en terminerai en disant que il y a des
bonnes relations de travail entre les
procureurs de la République et les jeux
instruction et les chefs de service
police judiciaire la situation sécurité
publique est un petit peu différente en
ce sens que les directeurs
départementaux sont en général beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus tournés vers le
travail avec les préfets qui sont depuis
quelques années à juste titre beaucoup
plus impliqué dans l'émission de
sécurité les procureurs en ont moins en
général le rapport avec les les chefs
départementaux et ont plutôt des
relations à quotidien avec des adjoints
en charge d'investigation judiciaire le
Livre blanc de la sécurité de 2020
exprimée clairement l'objectif de
renforcer l'autorité des préfets sur la
police nationale donc janvier en projet
que je résumerai très vite puisque alors
là je parle d'aller plus réinitiale qui
je le rappelle consistait si je l'ai
bien compris à rassembler à l'échelon du
département tous les services de police
sous l'autorité d'un responsable
départemental unique lui-même placé sous
l'autorité du préfet qui serait le chef
de 4 filières sécurité publique
renseignements police aux frontières et
investigations police judiciaires avec
la disparition d'un certain nombre de
services qui verrait donc une sorte de
fusion au sein d'une filière
investigation aux côtés des enquêteurs
des sûreté départementales de la
sécurité publique qui aujourd'hui traite
un spectre on va dire plus bas de la
délinquance le but de la réforme si j'ai
bien compris là encore et était de
mettre au fonctionnement tuyau ou en
silo ce qui à mon avis effectivement
tout à fait légitime au sein de la
police nationale où chaque service ne
rencontre qu'à sa direction centrale et
de renforcer les pouvoirs des préfets et
de porter bien évidemment c'est ce
qu'avait dit je crois monsieur le
ministre une attention prioritaire à la
criminalité du quotidien alors j'ai
évoqué les dangers que l'état initial de
ce projet pouvait susciter
il est rare
ça me fait vouloir faire mauvais esprits
de voir un projet susciter une telle
unanimité dans les critiques il y a
quand même pas beaucoup de projets qui
arrivent à réunir contre lui des
policiers des magistrats et des avocats
d'abord je crois que l'échelons du
département n'est pas adapté au
traitement de la criminalité organisé
les groupes criminels les plus
structurés sont très mobiles ils
s'entraident ils étendent la
ramification à travers tout le
territoire et à l'étranger
les sources sont sûrs c'est le rapport
du cirasco le cirasco Suns ministère de
l'Intérieur le rapport annuel j'ai aussi
travaillé sur ce sujet moi il y a 3 ans
comme Alain beloubet m'avait saisi d'un
rapport sur la criminalité organisée
financière on avait à l'époque fait le
constat que les dossiers de criminalité
organisés ne cessaient de se
complexifier notamment dans des modes
opératoires sophistiqués je nous cite
utilisé par les groupes criminels et de
s'internationaliser on avait à l'époque
fait le constat que le haut du spectre
de la criminalité n'était pas
suffisamment bien traitée et on avait
souligné alors en 2019 la dimension
ultra régionale voire nationale tout
comme l'internationalisation de ces
modes opératoires on est vraiment à
l'opposé d'un traitement dans la logique
sur les départementales enfin je pense
que le projet dans son état initial
toujours ne pas aux enjeux de la qualité
des procédures au nombre suffisant
d'opéji à travers un projet comme ça je
crois que il y a bien évidemment on se
rend compte qu'il semble en fait
peut-être répondre à d'autres objectifs
qui sont ceux de la gestion de la
pénurie des enquêteurs au PG en sécurité
publique la concentration des par la des
spécialisation à la concentration des
effectifs et la recherche des résultats
plus visible en matière de délinquance
du quotidien de maintien de l'ordre mais
ce faisant le projet peut avoir
peut-être certains avantages pour la
sécurité publique l'inconvénient serait
bien évidemment de toucher et d'abîmer
un outil qui fonctionne la PJ qui
fonctionnait plutôt bien
dans des enquêtes complexes et longues
qui touchaient principalement à la
criminalité organisée et qui risque donc
d'astre impacter ce que j'y est encore
encore plus vrai bien sûr pour le
traitement de laquince financière donc
le risque avec un tel état du projet
c'était de voir l'APG perdre son
indépendance son niveau de technicité le
risque que la priorité soit donné au
traitement des cibles les plus visibles
et je reviendrai au travers des
questions que vous m'avez posé et les
plus facile à traiter au détriment des
infractions les plus graves les plus
complexes les plus cachés les plus tapis
on pourrait résumer tout ça sous le
terme politique du chiffre
enfin le danger d'affaiblir le principe
de direction de l'enquête par les
ministres du parquet du jeu instructions
alors bien sûr sur le papier des choses
ne bougent pas l'article 12 reste ce
qu'il est le risque est quand même fort
de voir devenir le ddpn sous l'autorité
du préfet l'autorité décisionnaires en
matière de politique pénale on fait en
renforçant l'autorité des préfets de
départements là aussi suivant la
personne était les préfets je pense
qu'il existe un un soupçon et un risque
d'interférence dans les enquêtes des
préfets des politiques et des élus donc
si vous voulez bien je réponds à vos
questions en étant le plus synthétique
possible la première question c'était
comment les magistrats répartissent-ils
les enquêtes entre les différents
services en application de l'article
12-1 du code de procure pénal donc
répartition sécurité publique PJ les
services police judiciaires sont-ils
parfois amenés à traiter des affaires de
la délinquance du quotidien dans quelles
conditions alors là aussi avec
l'expérience qui est la mienne je pense
pas que ça ait beaucoup changé en
répartit les enquêtes en général en
fonction de la gravité des faits de la
complexité des investigations et de la
compétence et de la technicité des
services d'enquête globalement les
services sécurité publique sont chargés
des affaires de petits témoignes
délinquance des infractions de voie
publique vol simple voilà gravées à
tantôt personne violence conjugales
petit trafic de stupéfiants usage
stupéfiants Rix violence volontaire
agression atteinte sexuelle petit
escroquerie vent à la sauvette etc et au
sein de la sécurité publique les sûr
départementale qui sont le service qui
ont le j'allais dire la meilleure
expertise en matière de effectivement de
faire un peu plus compliqué sont elles
chargées plus souvent des affaires de
violence urbaines et des trafics de
stupéfiants les affaires criminelles non
par contre les affaires de criminalité
organisées financière sont de fait
quasiment toujours confiées à des
services spécialisés je pense bien sûr
Section de Recherche en zone gendarmerie
et en zone police au service de police
judiciaire c'est-à-dire direction zonale
de l'APJ service territoriaux ou en tant
de police judiciaires et là-dessus une
place quand même il y a 8 juridictions
internationales spécialisées en mode
pays aujourd'hui les Gers qui traitent
le haut du spectre de cette criminalité
elle travaille quasi exclusivement soit
avec des offices centraux soit beaucoup
plus souvent avec des directions zonales
de police judiciaire ou avec des
sections de recherche
la seconde question
on peut parce que ça ça sera plutôt par
écrit peut-être qu'on peut avoir des
questions plus entre guillemets générale
et éventuellement si
je peux en lancer une c'est de rebondir
sur ce que vous avez dit
concernant donc la police est et se dire
que on a entendu dire que enfin on
entend que cette réforme veut conduire
peu ou proue à l'organisation de la
gendarmerie nationale à la préfecture de
police et se calquer un peu sur cette
organisation donc est-ce que dans
l'organisation alors si d'abord
peut-être que vous ne pensez pas et si
éventuellement ça se rapproche de cette
organisation est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
rencontre des difficultés
vous rencontrez des difficultés avec le
traitement des affaires judiciaires qui
sont suivies par la gendarmerie et la
préfecture de police si oui pourquoi et
si ça n'existe pas ces difficultés alors
pourquoi ça serait plus à craindre si
c'est si ce sont des si c'est la police
judiciaire de la police nationale
je pense que le postulat n'est pas bon
la réforme
on peut pas dire que la réforme mettrait
les choses sur la même organisation que
la gendarmerie et la préfecture de
police pour moi c'est pas le cas il y a
des points communs mais il y a aussi de
fortes différences il y a des points
communs sur l'unité de commandement
c'est vrai que dans l'organisation de la
PP et dans l'organisation de la
gendarmerie vous avez une unicité de
commandement au niveau du département
à Paris vous avez un préfet le directeur
de la sécurité publique est placé sous
l'autorité d'un préfet c'est vrai en
faisant de gendarmerie tous les services
du département c'est un homme un
commandement une mission des moyens tout
ça c'est le sous l'autorité du du
comment un groupement de gendarmerie qui
est lui-même placé sous l'autorité du
préfet mais la comparaison s'arrête là
parce qu'il y a de grosses différences
en gendarmerie vous avez les sections de
recherche qui sont chargées du
traitement de la grande criminalité et
délinquance organisée financière qui
sont pas du tout placés sous l'autorité
des commandants de groupe le
départementaux elles sont placées sous
l'autorité des commandements des
commandants de région ce qui est tout à
fait différent et sur la préfecture de
police
la comparaison en réalité aurait été
véritablement fidèle dans l'organisation
qui était celle de la PP il y a 20 ans
ou les commissariats parisiens étaient
organisés en District dans lequel était
fusionné tous les services qui
traitaient tous les dossiers et ce
modèle a été abandonné à la fin des
années 90 ou au début des années 2000
j'ai pu très bien pour avoir un
dispositif dans lequel effectivement le
préfet de police a la main mise sur plan
administratifs en termes d'autorité sur
tous ces services mais on a deux
paysages très différents entre lesquels
les magistrats peuvent tout à fait
choisir comme ils le veulent vous avez
des services sécurité publique avec des
commissariats de sécurité publique dans
chaque arrondissement qui traite
effectivement les affaires de petite et
moyennes délinquance et vous avez une
direction régionale des polices
judiciaires qui est articulé avec une
fondée autour de la création de brigades
centrale brigade criminel BSP BRI etc et
de district de police judiciaires qui
sont là pour traiter l'eau du SPAC de la
dinguence Parisienne et les affaires les
plus graves donc c'est pas du tout comme
le projet initial tel qu'il était bâti
encore une fois point commun il y a
certainement une unité du commandement
qui présente pas pour le judiciaire de
de l'inconvénients particuliers moi je
comprends tout à fait la cohérence qu'il
peut y avoir à placer sur un mode
administratif sous un mode de
commandement unique et notamment en
termes d'obligation de compte rendu un
ensemble de services mais à Paris on a
le choix entre des saisir des
commissariats saisir la sûreté
territoriale ou saisir des services
départementaux ou des districts de
police judiciaires et en gendarmerie on
a le foie entre saisir des services
locaux une section de recherche
de votre présence et de ses réponses
trois questions
vous les avez évoquées dans dans votre
propre volliminaire il y a un vrai sujet
de désaffection pour la fonction
judiciaire assorti d'une difficulté
récurrente de qualité des procédures
et on a le sentiment que par la réforme
qui est envisagée j'ouvre une parenthèse
dont finalement c'est quand même pas
grand chose parce que on apprend là il y
a eu un article d'un journal ou le la
personne chargée de conduire la réforme
donne quelques éléments nouveaux il y
aura des divisions
spécialisées sur la criminalité
organisée des divisions territoriales
les sûreté changeront de nom le
procureur pour un noter les directeurs
départementaux donc dans le feuilleton
on apprend des choses au fur et à mesure
je ferme la parenthèse est-ce que la
réponse à la désaffection et la qualité
des procédures
passent par aller puiser de la
compétence dans la politique judiciaire
sur pour les affecter en sécurité
publique est-ce que on risque pas
d'avoir une affaiblissement des
spécialités métiers et est-ce que la
réponse au fond n'est-elle pas
finalement dans la question de l'unité
de commandement
et qui permettrait
d'avoir une meilleure vision entre ce
que fait la main droite est-ce que fait
la main gauche dans l'organisation
actuelle la police nationale
ce que je trouverais préjudiciable c'est
de faire disparaître purement simplement
des services qui ont su préserver une
technicité et une qualité je sais qu'au
niveau de l'APJ à un moment donné la
discussion il y a eu qui a eu il y a eu
des contre-propositions de certains
responsables de la PJ qui consistait à
maintenir toutes les échanges police
judiciaire quitte à les mettre sous
l'autorité de ddpn ou des NPN pourquoi
pas je vois pas en quoi l'unité de
commandement entraîne inéluctablement la
disparition de service qui risque de
perdre leur technicité leur compétences
en étant fondu dans un espèce de
baguemar qui devra traiter à la fois des
affaires de petites délinquance de
moyenne délinquance et le grand
délinquance c'est ça que je pense qu'il
fait peur aux collègues d'autant que là
aussi je disais on n'a pas une vue
exhaustive et je pense que les
inspections qui ont été ordonnées
forment du bien là-dessus mais ça parle
quand même sur les expérimentations j'ai
pas compris que dans les endroits où
dans les départements où la réforme à
visiter expérimentée il y a des
résultats parfaitement profitables et
que notamment grâce à la
l'expérimentation on est pu réduire le
stock des procédures en souffrance dans
les commissariats c'est pas du tout ce
que j'ai compris j'ai même plutôt
compris l'inverse en ce sens que
l'expérimentation qui avait été faite
n'avait pas véritablement eu un impact
là-dessus
mais ça je pense que l'expérimentation
des l'évaluation des inspections fera la
part des choses donc si vous voulez
après donc encore fois l'unité de
commandement pourquoi pas moi j'ai
toujours lutté dans tous les endroits où
je suis passé même avec ma culture
judiciaire contre les fonctionnements en
silos je trouve que l'Ariane pire donc
c'est pas moi qui vont venir va venir
vous dire aujourd'hui qu'il faut pas
lutter contre les fonctionnements en
silo bien sûr qu'il faut lutter contre
le fonctionnement si l'eau mais je pense
qu'il faut essayer d'avoir un système
qui préserve la qualité d'un outil et
qui fasse que si demain un procureur ou
un juge instruction doit saisir un
service avec des investigations qui vont
se
dérouler hors du département ou dans
l’inter région ou à l'international on
puisse avoir la garantie que le chef du
service concerné donnera les moyens de
faire ses enquêtes quant à ce que vous
évoquez la dernière chose je vois où on
met d'y répondre le fait que le ddpn
soit évalué par les procure de la
République c'est très bien je vais la
plupart ne l'était pas parce que je vais
être désagréable on est on
évalue que les OPJ vous avez un sérum de
directeur départemental de sécurité
publique qui ne demandent pas leur
habilitation au PJ pour justement éviter
d'être évalué par les parquets donc ça
c'est une bonne chose pour autant il
faut rester objectif et garder les pieds
sur terre c'est pas une mesure
révolutionnaire qui assurera le succès
ou l'échec de l'opération mais c'est
vrai que ça va dans le bon sens il faut
le reconnaître
oui Monsieur le Procureur général
bonsoir on prête à Benjamin d'israëli
ancien Premier ministre britannique
cette phrase
réformer ce qu'il faut préserver ce qui
vaut
[Musique]
cette réforme
l'efficacité est toujours mise en avant
la vraie question c'est est-ce que cela
est lié en fait à la volonté d'un
contrôle politique je pèse mes mots liés
au préfet au travers du ddpn peut-être
que vous répondrez pas pour des
questions de n'oublions de réserve
éventuellement je n'en sais rien quoi
d'autonomie est certaine mais en tout
cas c'est l'interprétation que beaucoup
d'entre nous en tout cas estiment et que
ça n'améliorerait pas l'efficacité de la
police judiciaire dans notre dans notre
pays vous avez que eu malheureusement à
connaître d'affaires extrêmement
douloureuse dans ce dans ce pays est-ce
que par exemple ces affaires auraient
été mieux traitées si la police
judiciaire était départementalisée dans
le cadre de la réforme qui est prévue
merci Monsieur le Procureur général je
dois dire que
j'ai écouté comme toujours avec un très
grand intérêt ce que vous avez dit et
d'ailleurs je dois dire que j'étais
parmi vos auditeurs de France Inter
et j'ai trouvé que ce que vous avez dit
à France Inter était clair
j'ai vu que ce que vous disiez là était
clair même si peut-être avez-vous fait
un effort pour entrer dans une logique
ou pour prendre en compte la logique qui
est présentée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur
mais j'ai le sentiment que ce que vous
dites et finalement très clair je crois
que à partir du moment où la police
judiciaire est sous l'autorité du
parquet
il est incompatible avec le fait qu'il y
ait un commandement unique de l'ensemble
de la police sous l'autorité d'un
responsable de la police je crois qu'il
y a
l'incompatibilité
n'empêche pas bien entendu comme vous
l'avez dit les contacts la coopération
la collaboration le c'est vrai que vous
avez dit que durant toute votre carrière
vous avez accusé le travail en silo si
bien que ma question c'est peut-être
même pas une question vous comprenez
bien le la complexité de la chose si je
pense que vous avez raison depuis France
Inter et que les arguments que vous
savez produits là font que vous
persistez à voir raison et que les
abodiations dont vous faites pas
montrent la grande l'esprit d'ouverture
qui est le vôtre mais finalement si l'on
est dans la logique du ministre de
l'Intérieur et nous l'avons beaucoup
d'interroger nous avons je crois que ça
ne marche pas que l'idée de compromis
sur ce sujet là et pourtant moi je
trouve que le compromis est parfois très
très utile mais l'idée de compromis ne
marche pas
et je voulais vous demander si vous
étiez en accord avec ça mais vous n'êtes
pas obligé de me répondre d'ailleurs
c'est une vérité générale
bien merci Monsieur
Richard puis madame de La gontronderie
je voudrais prendre un autre sujet qui
est la nécessité je crois reconnue
unanimement d'une refonte du code de
procédure pénal
quelle méthode pensez-vous la plus
adaptée pour arriver
au Nouveau code de procédure pénale
une observation superficielle me fait
penser que ce qu'on fait pour tous les
codes
qui est une habilitation
à droite constant le fonctionne pas pour
deux raisons la première c'est que nous
n'avons semble pas les conditions
politiques pour que le Parlement
consente à une telle habilitation avec
deuxièmement l'objet n'est pas de le
faire à droite constant
en même temps
de partir avec un projet neuf
qui va représenter deux ou trois mille
articles
dans une procédure législative à
bénitieux
voyez vous une autre voix qui permet
d'aboutir car cette nécessité est
urgente merci Monsieur
Président
Monsieur poker général je dois dire que
sur la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
nous avons un peu de difficultés me
semble-t-il à identifier le process le
calendrier les modalités etc
hier nous avons additionné le garde des
sceaux sur son budget et une fine et
nous étions déjà avec lui depuis deux
heures
quelques questions qui ont été posées
sur ce point et
il a évoqué le fait que des évaluations
donc de l'expérimentation était
prévue ou en cours sont comprennent très
bien voilà
donc tout un travail d'évaluation il a
été d'une prudence évidemment de suce
sur l'appréciation sur le fond de la
réforme c'est bien normal vous avez
vous-même il y a quelques instants fait
référence aux évaluations avec une
formule elle aussi assez floue je dois
dire indiquant je crois savoir etc donc
en un mot commençant est-ce que
l'expérimentation
a été évaluée
quelles en sont les conclusions et
comment comment peut-on s'appuyer dessus
c'est à dire comment peut-on en avoir
connaissance que sais-je évidemment je
vous pose cette question vous n'êtes pas
celui qui qui est censé mais voilà si
vous pouvez nous aider à y voir plus
clair dans ce sujet ce serait très utile
merci
en général vous avez la parole
j'espère je vais rien oublier dans les
questions
pour répondre à la question de monsieur
le sénateur canin non je pense que le
département n'est pas le bon échelon
bébé à plusieurs titres d'abord on
regarde la complexité vous avez pris des
exemples à l'évidence on n'est pas dans
une approche départementale c'est
évident moi je
si vous voulez on est dans du grand
écart il y a un vrai problème de
cohérence derrière tout ça on nous
demande à nous plan judiciaire de nous
spécialiser de plus en plus on le voit
dans l'organisation judiciaire depuis
les lois permanent 2004 vous avez des
Gires vous avez les pôles d'épaule de
santé publique il y en a deux maintenant
il y a la jeune Alco qui traite du
spectre du crime organisé on se
spécialise de plus en plus comment bâtir
un système dans lequel l'un des acteurs
se spécialistes et et l'autre va se
devenir plus généraliste qu'avant ça
match pas je suis désolé il y a un vrai
souci donc
moi je pense que il y a il y a
effectivement un vrai enjeu derrière
tout ça et il y a une autre approche en
plus par rapport au département qui fait
que ça c'est dans l'expérience par
côtière on sait aussi que parfois on
parle souvent dépayser des dossiers on
peut les dépayser au niveau d'un d'une
poursuite ou d'un jugement il y a aussi
des fois des enquêtes qui méritent
d'être dépayser quand vous avez par
exemple une sécurité publique d'un
département qui va travailler avec une
administration au quotidien dans le chef
fait l'objet d'une plainte il est
peut-être plus simple dépayser de
l'enquête et de l'envoyer ailleurs là
l'utilité d'un service régional est
assez évidente quand vous avez des
violences urbaines avec des policiers
qui ont été victimes de mener très grave
de la part de délinquants locaux il est
quand même mieux de donner ça à un
service qui aura un certain recul par
rapport au fait dont on était victime
les collègues quand vous avez une
affaire de violence de de d'usage
légitime ou légitime d'armes à la suite
de refus récupérer là aussi il vaut
mieux avoir des services qui ont dans
certains recul et qui n'appartiennent
pas au même service que le policier qui
a fait usage son arme donc je pense que
il faut préserver il faut préserver tout
ça sur la seconde question
moi je crois je veux pas et l'idée la
question je pense qu'il est pas
forcément incompatible de vouloir
réformer je pense qu'il faut préserver
un outil encore une fois je pense pas
qu'il soit illégitime de vouloir
réformer mettre de l'ordre dans en
termes de commandement
je pense qu'il est pas illégitime de
vouloir réformer les choses regarde la
baisse du taux d'hallucination notamment
en matière de petits et moyenne
délinquance donc je vais pas venir vous
dire qu'il faut pas toucher je pense
qu'il faut on peut toujours faire mieux
il faut toujours chercher à faire mieux
par contre il y a un véritable enjeu
quel que soit le mode qui sera déterminé
il faut bien comprendre que le
[Musique]
aussi les parquets n'ont pas les moyens
des enquêtes qu'ils ont ordonnés ils ne
peuvent pas mettre en œuvre leur
politique pénale
et ça je suis désolé donc on ne peut pas
aller vers un système qui consisterait à
faire et ça les expérimentations l'ont
démontré du directeur départemental de
la police nationale quelqu'un qui serait
arbitre en réalité des décisions du
parquet et qui feraient ce qu'il aurait
envie de faire imaginez par exemple vous
êtes procureur à
en Saône-et-Loire vous voulez saisir la
DDSP local avec une enquête qui va
amener à faire des investigations dans
la région lyonnaise et peut-être sur la
grande Bourgogne etc est-ce que vous
croyez franchement que le directeur
départemental va accepter de distraire
des effectifs dont il a besoin au
quotidien pour aller travailler sur des
enquêtes au long cours qui vont durer
des semaines ou des mois dans des
départements dont il a pas forcément
grand chose à faire et là-dessus je
pense que il suffira pas une doctrine
d'emploi parce qu'une doctrine d'emploi
c'est bien ça rassure mais ça peut être
changer du jour au lendemain donc moi je
j'ai pas la réponse viracle mais je
pense qu'il faut avoir un système qui
préserve le libre choix donc qui
préserve effectivement l'existant à
travers des services zono-intérêts sur
notre police judiciaire qui permettent
au procureur de choisir et dans un monde
idéal peut-être un jour on peut rêver
d'un système dans lequel les procureurs
de la République auraient peut-être
leurs mots à dire en termes
d'affectation des moyennes en les
enquêtes qu'ils ont ordonnées et il y
aurait peut-être un peu plus de
cohérence au niveau au niveau de l'État
là-dessus sur la troisième question de
sénateur Richard sur le le code
transfert pénal je pense qu'une
simplification j'ai pas compris que ça
serait une simplification en droit
constant à 100%, je pense qu'une
simplification à droit constant ne règle
aucun des problèmes si c'est uniquement
pour toi elle était le code et éviter le
redondance ça va pas régler le problème
de la crise de la filière investigation
qui fait que les gens sont plus là je
vais vous raconter une histoire comme
j'étais procure Paris je me plaignais
toujours des insuffisances effectives de
la PJ on a vu après les attentats toute
une vague de mutation intervenir au sein
de la police tout le monde voulait
quitter la filière investigation pour
aller où dans l'enseignement
effectivement c'est bien il y a beaucoup
moins de procédures même s'il y en a un
peu plus avec la loi de juillet 2015
aujourd'hui donc c'est même de connu
cette situation où quand je me plaignais
de l'insuffisance effective de certaines
brigades à la PJ et où le directeur de
la Belgique créer des postes il y avait
pas de candidats
donc je pense qu'il faudra certainement
qu'une simple toiification
codification à droit constant pour
simplification à avoir consomme pour
arranger tout ça là où les choses se
compliquent c'est que vous savez mieux
que moi les réformes de fonds de la
procédure pénale
dépendent aussi d'un phénomène bloquant
on n'arrivera pas à réformer une forme
des choses tant qu'on n'aura pas réglé
le problème du statut du parquet qui a
aujourd'hui un effet bloquant sur
l'évolution des choses enfin moi c'est
ma conviction donc je pense que
l'exercice risque d'être compliqué et je
suis pas sûr que ça règle les choses
alors qu'à l'autre marge de manoeuvre il
y a effectivement la volonté mais j'ai
cru comprendre qu'elle existait
aujourd'hui c'est très bien à condition
que la formation soit au niveau il
faudrait avoir beaucoup plus d'officher
de police judiciaire notamment certains
en sécurité publique et avoir des
officiers de sécurité de police
judiciaires que soient beaucoup mieux
encadrés d'en revoir effectivement les
effets néfastes de cette réforme de 95
qui est dont on paye encore le prix
aujourd'hui et dernière chose que je
voudrais indiquer par rapport à
l'expérimentation
c'est vrai effectivement j'avais vécu
quand j'étais au parquet de Lyon dans
les années 95 il y avait eu une un
projet de réforme de la
départementalisation de la police
nationale hors police judiciaire qui en
réalité n'avait pas fonctionné du tout
puisqu'il avait été abandonné au bout du
jumeau ou deux ans
sur la dernière question
c'est
oui l'expérimentation
là aussi madame massénatrice moi j'y
vais de façon nuancée et prudemment
puisque les langues se sont dédiées un
petit peu moi j'ai pas ressenti des
effets particulièrement positifs sur
l'expérimentation dans les les
départements dans lesquels effectivement
ça a eu on a eu l'occasion de voir de
voir de voir de voir de voir fonctionner
tout ça je recherche
on a on a eu
quand même
des choses pas très positives qui sont
remontées nous ce qu'on nous a dit
encore une fois ça méritera d'être
confirmé ou infirmé par l'inspection je
suis prudent
on nous a dit que les procureurs étaient
marginalisés en élaboration les
détermination de la politique pénale
avec une situation dans laquelle
finalement l'autorité judiciaire n'était
plus vu que comme un gestionnaire de
flux
voilà c'est à dire que on s'en sort pas
on a des stocks en souffrance vous allez
nous aider à les traiter avec notamment
des politiques anticipées de révision
des procédures notamment de classement
on nous a dit qu'il y avait une absence
de prise en compte des priorités de
politique pénales définies par le
parquet alors c'est vrai qu'en général
au sein de l'État on le voit dans les
circulaires il y a des thèmes communs de
politique pénales qui sont portées à la
fois par l'intérieur et par la justice
mais on n'est pas dans un monde parfait
il y a aussi parfois certains certaines
bizzbeeilles et il y a pas toujours
l'unanimité dans certaines choses on l'a
vu d'ailleurs notamment pendant la crise
de la pandémie ou il y avait des
priorités au niveau de la sécurité
publique elle est peut-être beaucoup
plus sur la pénalisation de la mise en
danger dans l'espace public alors que
certains parquets auraient voulu
effectivement qu'on mette beaucoup plus
l'accent sur des violences personnes ou
des attentes bien qui se commettaient
d'une façon un petit peu différente donc
il y a pas d'unanimité là-dessus et là
aussi il faut bien prendre conscience du
fait que si c'est le seul VPN qui est
décisionnaire dans ces matières là le
procureur risque par contre coup de pu
avoir les moyens de mettre en oeuvre la
politique pénale et on a eu des retours
alors la plus précise notamment sur des
parcs ultramarins avec discours
indiquant que dans la pratique ça c'est
notamment pour la Guadeloupe des
magistrats du parquet qui n'étaient plus
libres de choisir le service d'enquête
qu'il souhaitait leur demande est en
filtré par le ddpn je cite moi ce qui
m'a été répété ne pouvant plus décider
en opportunité du service d'enquête qui
leur paraît le ne nous a même de décider
et puis aussi il nous faut une
focalisation un peu particulière sur le
fait que tout le monde est d'accord pour
améliorer
l'information des élus sur l'évolution
de la criminalité ces modes de
traitement pour autant les élus on peut
pas forcément à recevoir un certain
nombre d'informations qui concerne
directement l'évolution à la conduite
des investigations je pense que c'est
pas leur rôle et il y a eu là-dessus un
certain nombre de retour sur l'outre-mer
stigmatisant le fait que certains élus
ultramarins avaient bien vu la bonne
filière pour avoir des informations
parfois très précises sur un certain
nombre de traitement d'affaires grâce
aux préfets et aux directeur
départementaux voilà mais tout ça je
pense que méritera d'être moi je suis
dans le on dit je suis l'homme qui a vu
l'ours là comme qui a vu l'homme qui a
vu l'ours je pense que ça sera tout le
l'avantage et le bénéfice de ces
inspections de faire la part des choses
et de démontrer quels avantages et quels
inconvénients merci beaucoup en général
alors les rapporteurs ont-ils d'autres
questions Madame bellerault et Monsieur
Durand c'est une question c'est que je
on croise avoir que les retours des
inspections ça sera pour le mois de
janvier donc en effet ça sera
certainement très éclairant
de questions brèves
vous ne savez fait état d'un certain
nombre de retours sur les
expérimentations nous en avons eu
nous-mêmes par les responsables de la
police qui avait à gérer ses
expérimentations on a déjà le sentiment
qu'un droit constant un certain nombre
de choses était possible par exemple en
matière de cossaisine et que ces
expérimentations qui sont déroulées à
droite constant et à moyen constant ont
pu dégager aussi où là des méthodes de
travail nouvelles donc est-ce qu'il y a
pas un champ à déjà investiguer dans
cette perspective là et puis deuxième
question c'est le contrôle politique
redouté par la tutelle préfectorale sur
la nouvelle organisation
la seule exception zonale à la logique
départementale concerne les atteinte à
la probité or vous l'avez indiqué en
début de propos la sensibilité d'une
affaire ça ne se résume pas à la seule
atteinte à la probité je vais vous
entendre là-dessus
alors là aussi j'y vais avec prudence
parce que j'ai pas les contours les
derniers contours du projet mais
effectivement j'avais entendu dire à un
moment donné que n'était préservé au
niveau zonal je crois que sa figurait
dans les organigrammes qui avait été
diffusé à PJ à l'époque de figuré
effectivement que la préservation de la
sphère atteinte à la probité à travers
le maintien si j'avais bien compris dans
les 17 PJ de deux entités de 6
enquêteurs chacune 6 enquêteurs pour le
blanchiment 6 enquêteurs pour la probité
et la corruption franchement c'est pas
sérieux c'est pas suffisant demain avec
qui vont travailler des juridictions
internationales spécialisées
avec qui
travaillera dans j'espère simplement que
c'est une problématique dont les
responsables ont pris conscience et que
l'outil sera préservé là-dessus je pense
que l'enjeu n'est pas du tout de
préserver le traitement des atteintes à
la probité ça c'est
certain c'est de préserver même je dis
pas qu'on puisse pas l'améliorer de
préserver dans sa totalité l'outil de
traitement de la grande criminalité
organisée et financière d'autant que là
aussi vous me permettrez une dernière
accroche les attentes à la probité ça
recouvre pas tout le champ de la
criminalité financière le traitement de
la crème des effets financière déjà ne
va pas bien il est très mal pour ne pas
dire parfois pas traiter le projet dans
son épuré initial pour moi c'était
vraiment la fin du traitement financière
parce que des ddpn ne seraient jamais
parti sur ce champ là
en général il y a une question on entend
enfin on nous dit et moi le constater
que la police judiciaire n'attirait plus
clair les policiers qui sortent d'écoles
restent la sécurité publique mais ne
vont plus en plus judiciaire pour des
raisons
de mobilisation 24 heures sur 24
principalement des questions de mode de
vie en réalité autre qualité de vie je
peux dire
et en même temps c'est pas vraiment on
nous l'a dit hier
comment voyaient les choses pour
améliorer cette situation
pense que c'est un problème qui est
véritablement systémique alors je
voudrais d'abord dire que bien sûr il y
a une crise évocation moi j'ai connu en
40 ans
engenda en gendarmerie mais aussi en PJ
des enquêteurs extraordinaires
effectivement qui comptaient pas leurs
heures et qui à un moment donné mais qui
c'est qui c'était vraiment une vocation
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de fonctions
de police qui ont des problèmes
personnels
en termes de séparation conjugale et de
choses comme ça parce que tout le monde
sait qu'il mène des vies dans lesquelles
ils donnent beaucoup de leurs personnes
et c'est pas toujours facile à concilier
sur un plan personnel donc je pense
qu'il faut la rendre hommage là dessus
pour autant il y a des crises de
vocation on l'a vu ça d'ailleurs
beaucoup après le traitement des
attentats mais j'allais dire ça fait
partie de la nature humaine quand vous
travaillez que vous êtes impliqué à fond
quand vous avez des fonctionnaires qui
ont des centaines et d'un sentir des
centaines d'heures à récupérer bon ça
dure un temps vous avez eu on l'a vu
d'ailleurs même entière d'identité
terroriste après les attentats il y a
des tas toute une de personnes qui
étaient impliquées là-dedans depuis 5 6
7 8 ans qui ont voulu changer et passer
à autre chose c'est logique donc je
pense que ça ça fait partie de la nature
je dis que c'est systémique parce qu'en
réalité c'est lié un sérum de facteurs
qui sont beaucoup plus généraux d'abord
je pense qu'il y a des problèmes de
motivation je pense qu'il est démotivant
particulièrement dans certains
contentieux de savoir qu'on va traiter
une enquête dans une affaire qui ne
verra pas le jour avant des années et
des années
quand vous savez qu'en matière
d'atteinte à la probité ou en matière
financière il faut parfois il y avait eu
des comptes qui avaient été fait dans
une cour voisine de Paris il fallait
entre 7 et 8 ans pour arriver à mener à
bien une attente à la profiter ou une
affaire financière je pense que c'est
des choses qui sont pas motivantes pour
des enquêteurs donc il faudrait avoir
quelque chose qui fonctionne mieux avec
une réduction des délais on est toujours
plus motivé quand on voit l'issue de ce
surcontravail c'est pas du domaine de
l'impossible après il y a des choses je
pense qu'il faut certainement
revitaliser la filière mais ça c'est
plus la responsabilité ministère de
l'intérieur mais je pense qu'ils ont
sûrement bien pensé avant nous rendre
peut-être la filière plus attractive à
travers des avantages de carrière des
avantages de fonctions des primes
soigner effectivement
assurer effectivement des vraies
récupération parce qu'encore une fois
ça ne peut fonctionner quand on et puis
faire un effort effectivement sur à la
fois l'encadrement et la multiplication
les OPJ on sait qu'il manque des OPJ
on partage tous la vocation incroyable
de ceux qui aujourd'hui sont en fonction
et même des missions difficiles c'est
vraiment tout à fait remarquable il veut
hommage de leur être rendu stop y a-t-il
d'autres questions
pas de question écoutez merci en général
de votre présence de la carte de votre
propos